[Music]
the world has a way of changing
and we change too i know some people
there are moments that separate us
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
man we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
[Music]
are you ready whatever's
[Music]
so how do y'all want to play this fast
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
[Music]
you fight for
crank it all the way up
it's good to be back we got no white
flag
we supposed to stop that hold on
i spent my entire life in your shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to home depot
i don't wanna die
[Music]
you